just another example that you know Zach
Levine helped me out a lot just with my
confidence all the depot hurt back and
forth again just he had such a positive
mindset talking to me it was it was
crazy clay like he wasn't he was
brutally honest yeah yeah yeah yeah
really honest with me how it's going to
be and I I got that Brotherhood oh man I
can see I could see the hurt in his eyes
when he talked to me and that's how I it
wasn't it was less about the words that
he was saying yeah I was looking to
Envision and I was looking he wasn't
even making eye contact he was just like
this is how it's going to be and now
when I talk to people that's the same
thing I'm like yeah this is how it's
going to be you know I'm saying
something